so I had one of my favorite reactions to
this film I walked out thinking to
myself how does this movie exist so what
is something you accomplish while making
Barbie that would make like young you
first starting out in this business say
I cannot believe that would be possible
one day and I'm so glad it is me being
in a Barbie movie that's not something I
ever imagined or thought possible for
myself mainly because like I wasn't a
Barbie girl I didn't grow up playing
with Barbies I didn't really like it
didn't resonate with me
um and and you know the fact that
there's a Barbie movie and that the
story has shifted and expanded to
include more of us to be able to be seen
in that iconic and very culturally
dominant brand is is you know that's
very unexpected and not something that I
ever thought I would say that I was a
part of you know I kept thinking about
how in the movie it heavily emphasizes
the fact that you know no matter what
toy you had as a kid it could stick with
you as an adult and still feel like some
sort of like relative form of
self-expression so if Barbie was not
your go-to what was the go-to toy and
maybe one that you find yourself you
know thinking about and influencing how
how you feel about yourself today I
really I have a really strong vision of
when I got
um a caboodle do you remember caboodles
for Christmas and I remember like
feeling like that was like this
the status like marker of my life like I
had a caboodle I'm sure like you know
I'm sure my mom got it like Rite Aid but
it was like everything to me and I put
everything in that caboodle like I spent
a lot of time I wonder what a caboodle
movie would be like I don't know I don't
think we need that movie I don't know
like if it's if it's something like if
it's bold and has such a strong voice
like this movie does sign me up for a
little literally any toy adaptation at
this point mine's the Jurassic Park toys
because I love them as a kid and now I
watch my niece playing with them and
it's just like the best one-two punch in
the world yeah that is the the thing of
like growing up and having kids and
nieces and smaller and watching how they
connect and resonate to to the same
things that we did and how like their
legacy toys Legacy Brands and but what
what is so exciting to me about getting
to be a part of this is you know this is
in a lot of ways Shifting the brand
Shifting The Narrative of what the
Barbie world world is and who gets to be
a part of it and what it means and I
think as a kid I what didn't resonate
with me was that Barbie was Perfection
and I was not perfect but that's not
what Barbie means today and that's not
what this movie means this to me what
Barbie stands for now is is like
embracing your joy and your expression
and that embracing that doesn't have to
be at odds with everything else that you
are exactly I feel like I I came at
Barbie the same way so seeing something
like this makes me very happy I want to
highlight Greta for a minute before I
have to leave you so you've worked with
many great directors do you notice there
being a shared quality among the
directing greats that you think signals
you they'll be a great collaborator for
you but then also for Greta what is
something that makes her stand out from
the bunch I mean credit is just
incredible and I think the amazing
talent that came to this film came for
Greta for her vision for how wonderful
she is to work with
um and you know I that I think that the
quality
[Music]
um that is shared with the directors
that I've had the best time with
um and have produced my best work is
trust like me trusting them and them
trusting me and I think Greta put
together
an incredible team of artists in every
department and she had a very strong
Vision but she also knew to then trust
the people she chose to come to the
party and give give us the freedom to
get to like do our best work inside of
the world that she made I like seeing it
and feeling it while I watch the movie
congratulations